[Applaus] immer mehr Deutsche glauben ja
gar keinen Gott mehr aber dafür an den
bekannten Thermomix du kannst ehrlich
das Gerät hat mein Leben verändern
klar Fast Food klassisches Fastfood ist für diese
gut bezahlte Klientel ein absolutes No-Go man sagt
grundsätzlich Mc Doof wenn man McDonalds meint
und wenn überhaupt dann geht man zu Subway denn
da kann man sich ja sein individuell individuelles
Sandwich selber zusammen kombinieren ja Sie haben
richtig gehört Subway man nehme zwei Stück
Pappkarton eine Handvoll Rasenschnitt drei
Lappen Toten Puten Arsch und ejakuläre etwas
zaubersoße oben drauf fertig ist das Sub es
kann ja gar nicht ungesund sein denn sie wurde ja
vor meinen Augen zubereitet die alte pansenbombe
wenn das einfach mal zu Hause ausprobieren
möchte sich einfach vom Pizza Bringdienst
was kommen lassen eine Karton mit fressen
hat nur mehr Nährstoffe ja das ist wahr
das ist ja der Widerspruch in dem wir
leben einerseits muss inzwischen jede
kleine Discounter Klitsche mindestens eine
Bioecke haben gleichzeitig gibt aber kaum
eine andere Industrienation pro Kopf so wenig
Geld für Lebensmittel aus wie Deutschland für
die große Mehrheit soll es nämlich billig sein
und vor allem viel und kaum einer will wirklich
wissen was in seinem Futter drin ist was einem
Ernstfall natürlich nicht vom rumheulen abhält
was in meinem Döner klebt ja ein altes Pflaster
aber ich habe doch eins 90 dafür bezahlt
man darf ganz getrost davon ausgehen dass
exakt dieselben Menschen die sich für
Engel in Menschengestalt halten weil sie mit
ihrem Q7 einmal am Tag zum bioladenbrettern
um schrumpel Gemüse zu kaufen dass ihn
schon auf dem Nachhauseweg wieder verwelkt
trotzdem gerne meine Fertigpizza in den Ofen
schieben und weil die Schrift auf der Packung
so wahnsinnig klein ist kriegen sie dann
leider nicht mit dass der Kochschinken auf
ihrer Pizza prostituto gar keiner ist sondern
ein sogenannter Klebeschinken Klebeschinken
oder für die die es nicht wissen für den wird
zunächst ein Schwein in die Luft gesprengt
und dann kommen Laboranten und Pappen
die Leichenteile mit einer chemischen
klebeschlosse wieder zusammen yummy passt aber
super zum sogenannten Analogkäse auf der Pizza
der nie eine Kuh von innen gesehen
hat tatsächlich gehört der sogenannte
Lebensmittelskandal inzwischen zur jährlichen
Medien Folklore weil wir zwar nichts wirklich
ändern an den Produktionsbedingungen in der
Lebensmittelindustrie aber uns ja trotzdem
gerne gruseln wegen der Dioxin Eier oder wegen
EHEC diesen Virus der uns gelernt hat das ist
völlig überraschenderweise doch nicht so eine gute
Idee war so ja Sprossen großflächig mit Kacke zu
besprühen Wahnsinn der hätte das gedacht wäre
wenn ich nie drauf gekommen wirklich ich kacke
jeden Morgen auf den Rucola Salat und der
ist nicht gesund verstehe ich nicht sowas
du musst unbedingt mal dein eigenes
Rezeptbuch rausbringen wirklich wirklich
seit 2013 steht ja auf jeder Lasagne
Packung Vorsicht kann Spuren von Nüstern
enthalten ja dann drehen sich alle
furchtbar auf und sagen wir dürfen
jetzt nicht so Tagesordnung übergehen und
dann gehen wir zur Tagesordnung rüber ja